on ne sait plus comment décrire les
violences qui déchirent
des membres de gang kidnappent des
enfants terrorisés aux portes des écoles
simplement pour renflouer leur butin de
guerre
si maintenant tente de s'interposer on
le tue devant tout le monde pour qu'ils
servent d'exemples ces violences
empêchent toute vie normale à part au
prince on peut même pas sortir chez soi
sans cette pensée se dire que on peut
sortir et ne pas revenir à la maison
donc oui on est en train de mourir la
jeune entrepreneur mère d'un bambin de
10 mois a lancé ce mot-clé sur les
réseaux sociaux la phrase que j'ai écrit
c'est je vis en Haïti je vais mourir
bientôt hashtag je vais mourir bientôt
c'est comme on est en train de
s'éteindre on est en train de
disparaître sous le poids de
l'insécurité surtout mais il y a pas que
ça il y a aussi le l'éducation qui est
en train de de partir en flamme parce
qu'il y a des écoles qui sont obligées à
cause de la situation de sécurité de
fermer leur porte moi je suis pour la
vie plus que pour la mais je comprends
là désolation de cette jeune dame dans
un éditorial coup de poing le
journaliste dénonce le silence des
médias et l'inaction des alliés d'Haïti
qui n'en ont que pour l'Ukraine l'État
haïtien n'a pas les équipements n'a pas
les moyens n'a pas les appuis ni du
Canada ni des États-Unis ni de récup ce
soir pour essayer de contenir cette
situation il faut dire que se connaître
en train de vivre c'est comme une espèce
de guerre civile sauf que en face c'est
pas un autre camp en face tout
simplement la population qui se fait
dessiner Franck Duval cite les chiffres
de l'ONU pour affirmer qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de civils tués en Haïti
qu'on Ukraine du 1er janvier à la
mi-mars l'ONU a comptabilisé 531
meurtres 300 blessés et 277 personnes
kidnappées presque tous des civils
innocents que pourrait faire le Canada
pour aider monsieur Trudeau continuait
de dire que si les Haïtiens s'entendent
le Canada finira un rôle on demande à ce
que les Haïtiens s'entendent depuis des
mois et des mois ça ne se produit pas
mais ce qui se produit en attendant
c'est les morts c'est les destructions
selon le journaliste les Haïtiens ne
souhaitent pas une intervention de force
étrangères qui finit trop souvent par se
vivre comme une occupation cette façon
de penser que c'est d'abord le pays
étranger qui doit aider ça ça nous doit
sortir de la tête Cindy pense que les
Haïtiens seraient capables de reproduire
la révolution de 1804 de se libérer une
deuxième fois d'une violence qui les tue
elle rêve pour son fils d'une vie sans
peur et elle y croit encore c'est un cri
désespoir qui maintenant crée un espoir
il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose ici
Sophie Langlois Radio-Canada Montréal